this is good soup good soup i said i'll
be doing three divot logic videos on
season six but i think it'll be better
if i do just two and condense the rest
of the season into this video and i'll
do away with episode introductions so i
can move through the season faster on
their way to negotiate with the masters
tyrion says a very cringy line to
missandei my own recent experience with
slavery has taught me the horrors of
that institution how many days were you
asleep
long enough to know not long enough to
understand
this is probably one of the most
disrespectful and tasteless things turan
has said despite maybe when he asked his
brother what brian's cooch was like but
the blatant disregard of missandei's
past horrors and tyrion train or light
to it is disgusting you can even see
greyworm exuding a great deal of anger
from that statement in the background
melt it down and add it to the others
for tyrion's terrible development of
character traits after david and dan
started writing him getting to the meat
of the scene though turian offers the
masters a seven-year plan to phase out
slavery and their economy and that seems
overly generous considering that they
almost killed daenerys burned down their
fleet killed sir barrison and numerous
other guards at this point they should
be pretty hostile towards the masters
given that they have no interest in
getting rid of slavery because as they
said it's basically their tradition i'm
still lived in chains as they have since
the dawn of time slavery is the way of
our world so tyrion expects the masters
to change on good faith and doesn't say
how he'll enforce the monetary policies
he pitched so what's the point to change
then they practically have no incentive
and would be more of a hassle to phase
out slavery for them it's also pretty
silly that the masters want daenerys to
leave while simultaneously destroying
her fleet it seems like dave and dan
kind of forget about the motivations of
the masters while deleting danny's fleet
for the greyjoy alliance
while on the subject of dumb plans
daenerys comes up with an idea to
overcome the cow and his blood riders
and by overcome i mean she just knocks
down a couple of fire stands which
somehow sets the entire building on fire
when the floor is composed of dirt and
stone i don't know how the fire was able
to spread so quickly the only
explanation i can think of is daenerys
coming in and dumping gasoline
everywhere before the encounter because
within 15 seconds of dany knocking down
the first fire stands the roof is
already falling down and burning and
whenever she knocks down a fire stand
the fire shoots out like a heat-seeking
missile running after the dothraki so
along with the fire acting in a
completely unnatural manner the scene is
also rapidly edited to make the fire
seem like it's spreading with lightning
speed and on top of all that fire
nonsense does dothraki just cower in
fear from daenerys instead of stopping
her from knocking down more fire stands
like after the first one they could have
easily walked around the fire and
grabbed her but nope let's just run for
the door like [ __ ] the most brave and
badass people in the entire world of
game of thrones are immediately turned
into incompetent babies so that daenerys
could easily overcome them
arya's awarded with her second chance
and is given an assignment to kill an
actress when looking into her target she
ends up watching an entire play this
play isn't really essential to the plot
by any means but it is interesting to
see the public view of the events of
king's landing and to see ari's reaction
so one place scene is alright but two
play scenes since there's one in episode
8 i think is pushing it it comes across
as david and dan putting in these filler
scenes to get past the 50 minute mark in
episodes and this is kind of a common
trend now because i pointed out two
other filler scenes within the first
three episodes getting back to arya
though her whole situation with the
faceless assassins feels contrived
because she's already on her second
chance and at every turn she is showing
hesitation like asking jaqen a bunch of
shady questions when it comes to her
target who wants her dad
that does not matter the younger actress
she's jealous because lady crane is
better
she seems like a decent woman
that alone is a massive red flag and it
seems like all she needs to do to seem
like a faceless assassin is to refer to
herself from the third person unless if
jaqen knows she's clearly bullshitting
and secretly admires her but later on he
sends away to go and kill her so that
wouldn't make sense i may as well just
get into that whole fiasco now to get it
over with because holy plot armor man
this is the first instance in the show
where it is absolutely unbelievable as
to how a character survived she gets
stabbed multiple times in the gut swims
through a dirty river that should infect
her wounds and then wanders through
braavos for god knows how long while
professionally bleeding everywhere and
ends up making it all the way to the
play to find the actress
and how convenient that she also knows
how to stitch her wounds and it doesn't
even stop there because the way finds
arya half a day later and arya is
somehow running around and doing parkour
like there aren't five holes in her
stomach it would make much more sense to
opt for minor injuries like slashes
instead of stab wounds or just cutting
out the chase scene altogether because
it comes across as comical
[Music]
then maybe we can have an actual
dialogue scene between the waif and arya
where they can finally hash it out but
nope game of thrones is all about action
now
after defeating the wave arya confronts
jaqen and a really confusing encounter
happens since arya killed the wave jaqen
says that she is now no one like what
are you talking about she reverted back
to being arya stark and killed the waif
in self-defense so how is arya no one in
this situation then when she has to say
that she's arya stark for the now slow
jaqen he seems visually confused and
shocked has he not known this whole time
what the [ __ ] is happening then jaqen
smiles and gives her a head nod like
everything is fine and lets her go
so has he admired her this whole time
this is all very conflicting because
surely he would be upset if he thought
arya was truly no one and has overcome
the waif but now is suddenly leaving i
don't even know anymore it just seems
like david and dan want to get arya out
of brahmos as fast as possible to get to
the twins in order to kill walder frey
which she does manage to get there in
one episode by the way so fast travel is
now active
i think it's time for our daily dose of
[ __ ] jokes with everyone's favorite
character euron greyjoy this whole scene
has a temperament of a common thread in
wall street bets all of euron's counter
arguments are honestly brain dead and
involve him spouting [ __ ] jokes saying
he'll do whatever yara said but better i
will build the largest fleet the world
has ever seen except i'm the one who's
going to build the iron fleet and he
openly admitted to killing balon greyjoy
which apparently not a single person
there was loyal to him despite people
gasping and seeming upset that he died
then after losing one of the cringiest
debates yar and theon casually steal the
iron fleet and at this point i assume
people are allergic to guarding ships
next the brand conundrum
it feels like david and dan paused bran
at the end of season 4 and hit resume
when season 6 began what has he been
doing throughout the entirety of season
5 we are left to assume that they've
been doing nothing but viewing random
events in the past instead of giving us
development for bran in which he learns
lessons tied to his power we end up just
getting glorified flashbacks why are we
even here the three-eyed raven i don't
know just because what is the goal to
watch every past major event and if
that's the case why would that even
matter because once bran becomes a
through-ed raven he can just any percent
speed run on learning all the
information in the world it would have
been much better to have a gradual
decline for bran into becoming a husk of
a human that transforms into the
three-eyed raven over the course of
season 5 and 6 who expands his knowledge
of working into other creatures or even
humans and also learns how to properly
manipulate time the time travel reveal
was outstanding but since dave and dan
decided to do nothing with it in the
later seasons the whole reveal and skill
set was rendered pointless because of
the terrible direction of decreasing the
presence of magic in the later seasons
bran ends up getting shafted as a result
i hate to interrupt my brand tangent but
hey the hound is alive this mostly seems
like a redcon given how he fell off a
cliff got his head bashed six times and
his nuts got reduced to jelly it's
plausible for him to survive if he
received immediate attention but brother
ray supposedly found him a while after
he fell and one thing that doesn't add
up is brother rey finding the hound in
the first place because firstly why is
this random dude out in the middle of
nowhere in the mountains and secondly he
said he had a wagon with him and the
terrain the hound felon is definitely
not suitable for a wagon so did this guy
randomly wander really far off the road
and happen to have stumbled upon the
hound i don't know this whole situation
comes across as blatantly forced to
bring cinder back into the story just to
get to the end point of clegane bull
which is not a bad ending for his
character by any means but the process
of bringing him back is undeniably
sloppy and raises a lot of questions
to throw in a quick point since quite a
bit of screen time takes place during
the siege of river run the way david and
dan deal with brendan telly aka the
blackfish is so upsetting because we
have this big buildup of the blackfish
refusing to leave his home and is
willing to fight anyone in his way to
then just suddenly dying off screen when
the lannisters breached the gates did
david and dan think he was an
unimportant character it comes across as
odd because dave and dan have injected
so much action in the later seasons that
you'd think they would give us a cool
action send off for this badass
character but they couldn't be bothered
going back to tyrion his peace plan with
the masters works briefly as the
celebration scene with greyworm and
missandei and for the third time this
season david and dan go for the dialogue
approach of comedy wouldn't it be funny
if breiman missandei tried wine look at
greyhound's funny face when sniffing the
wine and then the rest of the scene
consists of them telling jokes to each
other at this point in game of thrones
any dialogue scene that doesn't contain
plot development is basically filler
content since dave and dan have a
remarkable talent of not knowing how to
develop characters with dialogue luckily
though this scene is halted by the
master showing up with their ships and a
plan to assault marine which is another
entirely different issue the masters
have had great success in disrupting the
health of marine by funding the sons of
the harpy to cause chaos within the city
at the beginning of season six we see
that marine is basically a ghost town
due to the amount of fear the sense of
the harpy have spread throughout the
city and since that was such a big issue
for daenerys's side tyrion desperately
tries to strike a peace bargain with the
masters which obviously shows to the
masters that their plan is working
really well so why not keep supporting
the sons of the harpy and claim that
they've gone rogue because there's no
way that the masters can beat daenerys
army for ground combat alone she has the
unsullied second sons and the dothraki
for the sons of the harpy they're just
normal people and aren't good at
fighting and their strength derives from
surprise attacks and overwhelming their
enemies with guerrilla fighting tactics
so using them in an all-out attack is
idiotic and they get wiped out for it
and then for the sea assault their plan
completely hinges on the fact that
viscera and rhaegal won't be able to
attack their ships i assume their only
intel on the dragons is that they're
locked away under the pyramid but
logically from their perspective they
would be let out to attack the ships
and to add they weren't even let out and
instead burst it out by themselves so i
don't know why vasarin and rhaegal
willingly stayed down in the dungeons or
even knew how daenerys returned in
general though this all-out attack from
the masters is very logical it seems
like david and dan are trying to quickly
wrap up that plot line so daenerys could
go to westeros by the end of the season
if the masters know that her goal is to
go to westeros then it would make sense
for them to wait until she leaves to
then attack marine if they really wanted
to but that would make too much sense
queen daenerys won't stay in meereen
forever
the path takes her westward for tyrion's
quote-unquote great work in marine
daenerys decides to make tyrion her hand
and this development is pretty shocking
given that she hasn't spent that much
time with tyrion since she's been taking
care of the dothraki and while taryn was
in control he made a lot of mistakes
turning at this point from daenerys
perspective hasn't really done anything
to earn the title and she doesn't even
know him that well so again this feels
like another rush development
and now it's time for the battle of the
bastards i've openly critiqued this
battle multiple times in past videos but
since this is a divorce logic video for
season 6 let's get into it before the
battle even starts jon and sansa have a
heated argument where sansa declares
that they obviously need more men
earlier i would have told you not to
attack winterfell until we had a larger
force or is that obvious when will we
have a larger force it's pretty wild
that sansa doesn't decide to relay the
information to jon that she has allies
with littlefinger and has access to the
veil with the veil alone they could
easily beat ramsay's army on top of
having the wildlings and other northern
houses supporting them also if they
announced that they had the support of
the veil in their pitch to other
northern houses then they probably would
have helped given that they were the
winning side but instead sansa complains
and bickers towards jon snow that he
needs to be doing a better job when
she's single-handedly handicapping the
entire battle david and dan completely
butchered the intellect of sansa by not
telling jon about the veil so that they
can have an engaging underdog conflict
of jon trying to defeat ramsay with a
smaller army if they were to attack with
the veil in the beginning then the
potential for losses would be
drastically reduced for instance if the
story was more realistic johnson would
have died considering that he survived a
cavalry charge eight aerostorms being
swarmed by enemies and being trampled by
his own men the plot armor on display is
crazy like yes the action looks
magnificent and the cinematography is
gorgeous but nothing here makes sense
from the contrived scenario of actively
handicapping yourself to make things
more interesting the plot armor and the
deutsche ex mocking the ending of the
veil arriving just in time to save
everyone makes this scene absurdly
stupid but is the action cool yes it is
and it's absolutely fine if you enjoy it
after the battle john and sansa have a
confrontation in which they say that
they need to trust each other more i
don't know why that's even an issue in
the first place before the battle
because jon has never been untrustworthy
towards sansa but whatever and that's
not even the biggest issue because jon
thinks sansa and says this
you're the lady of winterfell you
deserve it we're standing here because
of you the battle was lost until the
nights the vale rolled in they came
because of you
on a technicality yes that's true but at
the same time she almost let john and
his entire army die imagine having the
best winning hand and almost losing it
david and dan just chalk up almost every
screw up as stupid incompetence that
comes and goes for our characters and
there are no lasting consequences for
sansa making this massive mistake
once littlefinger is done stalking sansa
from behind the trees he comes out and
says he wants the iron throne with her
by his side at this point in the story i
don't know why sansa doesn't expose
littlefinger for killing lysa aaron and
to have him killed i know that he just
helped sansa by bringing in the veil but
that was the only thing sansa needed him
for and he has proven to sansa that he
acts in his own self-interest and will
likely betray him again hell she even
calls him out on that you've declared
for other houses before lord baelish
it's never stopped you from serving
yourself
only a fool would trust littlefinger and
if one of you were planning to harm the
other in any way
wouldn't she be on about to intercede so
why is she letting him meander around
winterfell and scheme for the entirety
of season seven littlefinger handing
sansa over to the boltons in season 5 is
an unforgivable act that has severely
traumatized her and by even entertaining
the notion of listening to littlefinger
again is incomprehensible
for the last big scene there's the great
sept explosion the main issue i have
with it is that there's no lasting
impact and no one cares that cersei
deleted a whole religion however i've
talked about that numerous times and i
briefly went over it in the last avoid a
logic video then for the rest of the
finale i already touched on flawed
scenes like john and sansa's
conversation tyrion becoming hands and
littlefinger mouth breathing on sansa i
hope you guys enjoyed the video and let
me know in the comments if i miss any
glaring flaws in season six